from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and China
this is food Wars
new season USA versus China I'm so
excited for you guys to see this and to
meet our new co-host tianrin USA versus
China let's go
drinks from McDonald's in China come in
three sizes small medium and big but for
some reason the medium is 444
milliliters which in Chinese basically
just means die die die which is super
unlucky so I guess they really want you
to either get the large or the soil the
drinks at a US McDonald's come in four
sizes the extra small where'd it go
sorry they forgot it the small the
medium and the large our large is 80.9
percent bigger than China's largest soda
let's see if that's true bound to be a
little bit in the lid
that is Blasphemous shame these people
shame this clown some of you over the
past several years has said something to
the tune of it doesn't count or it's
wrong because we add the ice reheat the
ice in there and that isn't a true
measurement which I don't believe but
fine for the first time ever I want to
measure this without the ice I'm solving
this once and for all so right away you
get even less soda let's get this up to
exactly 32 fluid ounces 32 ounces of
Coca-Cola in the supposed 32 ounce
McDonald's cup I'm so sick of this why
are they saying 32 fluid ounces look
just say 30 or 31 it's fine you remove
McDonald's a fries come in three sizes
small medium and large American fries
come in three sizes small medium and
large we will now weigh our largest fry
so what about McNuggets here in China
you can only get them as an order of 5
or 10 which is really just two portions
of five that's cute China real cute here
in the US we have way many more nugget
options four piece for your infant six
piece ten piece 20 piece and our largest
the 40 piece all the math heads watching
will be quick to point out that this is
300 percent of China's largest portion
so here are all the McDonald's menu
items from China that you won't find in
the US here are all the McDonald's items
in the US you won't find in China oh my
god I've been staring at this for so
long this is incredible check out the
back it's an origami Apple this is the
best and see what we got a hamburger
mini fries a drink a corn Cup
[Music]
oh my God this is way better than the
Hamburglar what do I have to build Pond
as well this is
I'm too old for this anyway if you don't
want a hamburger you can also change
this out for a fish fillet or for four
pieces of nuggets you can also get the
corn cup changed out for apple slices
but they will cost you one quite extra
and with the juice you can have either
apple juice milk or water so only
healthy options here in China's
McDonald's okay now on for the toy so
this is going to take a while give me a
second
and then something flips out from behind
us groin in here it's coming together oh
it's a it's a basketball hoop
oh my God this is ingenuity at its best
look we can play Hoops with this three
two one
I noticed that his Happy Meal even the
box was a toy in America our Happy Meal
box
is another opportunity for an
advertisement all new season of the mass
singer on Fox check it out Jesus this is
Shameless some of these kids remember
before the extra small fry found it more
nuggets a four piece apple slices our
toy is decidedly not a puzzle everyone
Kermit the Frog was in there that was
weird okay what is this who what
celebrity was the fox oh it's Wayne
Brady okay I've heard of him but is his
head in here
oddly enough shows the Stark difference
between China and the US there's has
this puzzle to put together ours is an
ad for a TV show
I say these are our exclusive beef
burgers here in China people mostly eat
pork so I think with the beef they've
really had to go the premium root so
you've got some interesting combinations
this is the German sausage double beef
burger but in Chinese the name is kind
of like the anti-vegetarian Tyrant so
they've got some pretty aggressive
marketing for this imaginarian Cruise
just pulsing his Peck sorry what is that
oh if this is what they call a German
sausage then I think the Germans will be
very angry here we've got a BLT double
beef Focus
I'm so sad what is this this is like a
BLT sandwich that's been set at the
bottom of your bag for a week I'm
excited about these though these are the
Angus Max thick beef burgers now
McDonald's have done premium
collaborations with Michelin starred
chefs in the past and they even have
these really super fancy packaging look
at that double cheeseburger
wow look at that the meat Patty sicker
than my son that's a proper Burger
it was very meaty incredibly cheesy this
is the double cheeseburger so I can
understand that for the vast majority of
Chinese people they're understanding or
access to Western food May really come
from fast food restaurants so this is
probably the gourmet burger experience
for the vast majority of the Chinese
population in the US you can get a
quarter pounder with cheese what the
heck there was two two Taps this is the
special two top Quarter Pounder which is
apparently and we also have a Double
Quarter Pounder if you want to increase
the meat someone wants to get their
daily vegetables here is the quarter
pounder with cheese deluxe swimming in
mayonnaise we saw the United States
called the McDouble if you want slightly
less cheese and a double cheeseburger we
got you covered quarter pounder with
bacon every once in a while there's like
a quarter pounder to put bacon on it and
I don't know they repackage it for a
celebrity and these are our exclusive
chicken and fish options so I want to
start you off with this which has since
become McDonald's best spicy Burger this
is the MC spicy chicken fillet
apparently it's 1 000 Shu which is a
Scoville unit and it's roughly
equivalent to the spiciness you get from
a spicy and numbing hot pot and those
guys are pretty spicy
hmm oh that's delicious you don't feel
the burnout first and then there's like
your tongue slowly starts to wake up and
it's like a frog in a pot it slowly
starts to realize it's being boiled
alive and by the end of this burger
you're gonna want that coke now this is
McDonald's best-selling non-spicy Burger
the grilled chicken sandwich which is
supposedly has no growth hormones in
their chicken feed
very heavy on the black pepper woof wow
I'm very excited about this this is the
crunch chicken fillet burger and in
Chinese the name is
it sounds like how it's supposed to say
car is kind of like crunchy and flu is
kind of like the juice kind of squirting
out so this should be both crunchy and
juicy oh that looks like a much better
piece of chicken
yes yes
I didn't get the car probably because
this has gone a bit cold but look at
that it is Juicy in there okay this is
the super spicy chicken fillet look at
this guy you know this is gonna be super
spicy it's orange
it's not out spicy
oh
yes oh
my God
very tasty finish that
and it's done
to the hospital you'll go and last but
in my opinion least the double fish
burger
chicken sandwiches there's something
that is new-ish the bacon ranch mcrispie
it's just okay there's also a bacon
ranch Deluxe Mac crispy with Deluxe
equals more vegetables the mcrispie is
something that we ordered and they
forgot and then now piling on the
vegetables you got them the crispy
Deluxe spicy in the Crispies this
Rebrand the crispy chicken sandwich
should be then the crispy
so McDonald's China has one roll option
which is this crispy pork and pickled
bamboo shoot wrap
that's tasty it's nice and crunchy very
spicy wow
mmm it's spicy it's sour anything that
has Citron pepperhorn in it it's just
incredible here we've got the mug spicy
wings which come in portions of two four
or nine straight up I wish we had those
wings those wings look really good also
I don't know if you've noticed but the
decoration here on the packet this is a
collaboration with a streetwear brand
called clots or clot and it uses
traditional Chinese aesthetic so here
you've got the lucky knot which is sort
of like a symbol for good luck and
Longevity as Chinese as it gets and this
is also the same flavor as the MC spicy
Burger I don't know if there's an
accurate translation for this this is
literally called
the same size as my palm a little bit
bigger the more crispy chicken
crispy wow
this is
very special we didn't think we'd be
able to get this today this is the spicy
Lobster flavored chicken tenders the
Chinese says which means you have to
shake it
oh let's try these babies there was no
need to shake it at all there's there's
no seasoning there at all it's just
literally it's it's just literally
chicken tenders
it's more of a an aspiration towards a
lobster though and we've got crinkle cut
fries oh how I've missed you nothing
beats a crinkle cut fryer in China we
have a bunch of different Barrel options
for example this one is the golden
arches buckets which actually didn't
come in a bucket they just put
everything into a box the name actually
is the reason why we got this because
McDonald's in China has officially
renamed to Zing gongman which literally
translates as golden arches and when
they did that they caught a lot of flack
everybody started laughing at them
nobody calls them the golden arches in
Chinese it's just McDonald's but legally
they are now known as the golden arches
featuring sauces you know what that
means Julie sauce talk here are all of
our exclusive sources garlic chili
that's pretty much it oh and no Citron
Source either that's an American
invention just like General Tso's
chicken but here in China you don't
really get sauces unless you ask for
them they come with the Nuggets Chinese
people expect food to be complete when
it arrives at your table you don't go
and add more sauce to it sauces in the
United States after more for dipping
Tangy barbecue spicy buffalo it's the
USA so you know we got that ranch honey
mustard honey which is not here I don't
know where it is mayonnaise which also
they did not include Mexican style salsa
these are our exclusive desserts I am
gonna try every single one of them we
can start with the Taro pie Taro is
kinda like a cross between sweet potato
and potato it's often used in desserts
in Asia you'll find them in everything
from pies to bubble tea
it's a bit like yam with a bit of jam
but it's subtly sweet for Chinese people
if you say a dessert is not very sweet
that's actually a compliment pineapple
pie also one of my favorites
that is
[Music]
I think I'm going to finish this well I
wanted to chew for a very long time
so here we've got the strawberry sundae
which has kind of melted already but I'm
sure it would have been amazing when it
first arrived in affogato and a matcha
flavored affogato and then here we've
got the mug flurries this is the
strawberry McFlurry with Oreo cookies oh
my gosh that is perhaps the most sinful
thing that you could have oh but it's so
good this is just a regular mcfry and
here is my all-time favorite mango
pomelo Sago flavored McFlurry it's very
different with the ice cream you still
got the uh the mango in there and the
pomelo it's very juicy it's tender like
little tiny Pips in there they kind of
Pop when you eat them oh just perfect
fried rice
in the US you can get yourself a
McFlurry with mini M M's for some reason
mini M M's taste better than regular M
M's I love mini M M's
hot caramel sundae it's classic I think
that's in China yeah I mean what's more
American than an apple pie look at this
thing let's crack that bad boy open we
got chocolate chip cookies shakes we get
three different types of shakes here at
a U.S McDonald's chocolate
classic chocolate strawberry personal
favorite
that's so good vanilla the classic are
exclusive drinks include the fuse iced
tea we've got the minute made orange
mcfloats bubble tea soy milk
pure milk Ceylon black tea which in
China we would call Red Tea which just
confuses you for fun I'm gonna go back
to here because this is the only thing I
want to try out of all of them
it tastes like orange juice it's just
plain old orange juice the US gives
yourself a Dr Pepper a Fanta orange and
an orange lava burst lemonade you also
get frozen drinks get a frozen Fanta
blue raspberry or frozen Coke McDonald's
also has smoothies a mango pineapple
smoothie and a strawberry smoothie
they make a decent smoother tunnels as
you can see we have an absolute ton of
breakfast options here in China I think
McDonald's has done fantastic in this
regard because the Chinese treat
breakfast as a very special meal we have
a very similar saying to eat breakfast
like a king lunch like a prince dinner
like a pauper so starting with the
sausage McMuffin with egg always a good
way to start the day you can get this as
a double as well next we have the ham
muffin it's just literally a piece of
ham some lettuce and two muffins so I
guess this would actually be a hamburger
and get this as a double as well next we
have the grilled chicken muffin
yeah
this chicken's been sitting around for a
while next we've got the the crispy
chicken McMuffin so this is the
breakfast version
of the such a big chicken chop breakfast
in the US we have so many breakfast
options starting down here the
sandwiches Egg McMuffin I mean maybe the
first fast breakfast sandwich to ever
hit the markets sausage McMuffin sausage
and cheese if you had noticed this is
all what we call an English muffin
because they're from England there's
also a bacon egg and cheese McMuffin but
the option that we have most for are the
scrambled egg Burgers scrambled egg
grilled chicken burger the scrambled egg
is very luminously yellow wow look at
that
very peppery they love their pepper hair
don't know so the scrambled egg sausage
Burger you'll notice that buns are
different now we're no longer on the
muffins we're back to regular buns oh
it's squeezing out isn't it scrambled
egg cheeseburger this is like the
brightest Burger I've ever seen in my
life it's definitely very portable I
think that's one thing that McDonald's
has done very well because Chinese
breakfast traditionally is is not too
portable in the sense that you need to
sit down to a lot of meals like if you
want to eat
um wonton in the morning or if you want
to eat some soups in the morning this
you can just take and go and of course
you can get the scrambled egg German
flavor sausage burger at least I give
you two as opposed to just one tiny
sausage this gets biscuits biscuits
sausage and egg biscuit so the biscuits
are the same breakfast sandwiches you
get in English muffin form but in this
biscuit form the American biscuit this
dry crumbly buttery biscuits there is a
bacon egg and cheese one for some reason
people in this country seem to want just
a biscuit and sausage but no sauce no
nothing this is as dry as if you'd go
into like a barber shop and take a
handful of hair clippings and just shove
them in your mouth this is their dry in
the U.S so we have something called
McGriddles and the griddles are
breakfast sandwiches where they replace
the English muffin and or biscuit with
pancakes so first of all they got the
McDonald's logo right there too
hilarious somehow to the miracle science
was able to inject syrup into these
pancakes
Sensational you can get your McGriddles
in sausage egg and cheese and then just
sausage
onto what I was going to talk about the
kanji kanji is a very traditional
breakfast item here in China it's
basically just rice porridge and it's
something that is kind of like chicken
soup for Chinese people in the sense
that if you fall ill you're going to be
given one of these plain with nothing
this I think is with Century egg but the
century egg it tastes a little bit like
a blue cheese version of egg in that
it's kind of like egg that's gone off
but in a very nice way and this adds a
nice savoriness to the Congee you can
also get it with pickles and bamboo
shoots and if you're going to get Congee
then usually you need to pair it with
what they call an an Asian dough stick
this is what we call a yotyal which is
literally a stick of fried though these
are absolutely amazing when paired with
stuff like soy milk and of course with
congee
you know you need to eat these fresh
deep fried they are so incredibly crispy
oh wow well done McDonald's like 10
hours later these are still crispy I'm
very impressed but we're still a little
bit worried because there should never
be this crispy after that long I wonder
what they've put in here
last but not least my German sausages
again it's not just sandwiches you guys
we also have something
in the US the big breakfast which is
totally in disarray this is this is like
the advertising for this breakfast I'm
sorry
the big breakfast with pancakes is good
hot cakes AKA pancakes there's no way
they're back they're like ladling the uh
right there's no way they're doing that
these have to be pre-made and they just
heat them up right so hot cakes and
sausage oh and they both come with syrup
so you know we got to do
yeah we also have a morning wrap with
ham the the wrap itself is is basically
frozen solid we can exchange that with
sausage which is also Frozen it's almost
like a piece of art now like you're
supposed to look at it instead of eating
it
wow Frozen in Time us McDonald's have
sausage breakfast burritos I mean I
can't even unfold it was like ripping it
apart they got scrambled eggs the
sausage it comes with Mexican style
salsa and McDonald's is actually pretty
good considering that this is like
probably the furthest you can get from
something from salsa and still legally
called Salsa if you're not trying to
completely destroy your insides first
thing in the morning you can get
yourself fruit and maple oatmeal seems
like your breakfast is trying to escape
your body an hour later you might
actually be able to hold this down
the options
so we have macarons right now we have
two different flavors chocolate and
berries these actually look really legit
pat yourself on the back this is really
good and these things are lamingtons
I've never actually had lamingtons
apparently they're basically Australian
sponge cakes which are covered in
coconut flakes and this is a lemon
flavored one
surprisingly addictive uh we have the
McCafe bakery at the McCafe Bakery you
get you know sweet treats not
necessarily for breakfast but probably
leaning more towards breakfast time but
bam blueberry muffin a cinnamon roll
with cream cheese frosting it looks like
a squishy
it most certainly is not and come on who
doesn't love an Apple Fritter an Apple
Fritter is a donut that tastes like
apple and it was shaped like it was just
squeezing someone's hand for some
strange reason these are our McCafe
drink options starting with the extra
milky latte without milk
a latte is two-thirds milk and then you
add oat milk in there I don't think we
can have much coffee
oh oh wow that is surprisingly good in
China oat milk has really really taken
off because a lot of people did not grow
up drinking milk a lot of Chinese people
are lactose intolerant and so oat milk
is definitely a very healthy alternative
and that's why we have the extra strong
chocolate with oat milk you can also get
this without oat milk extra strong
matcha milk extra strong matches oh we
have so much matcha extra strong
chocolate smoothie extra strong milk and
vanilla smoothie and the matcha milk
with matcha jelly
oh I want to ask we absolutely love
matcha here in China I don't know why
it tastes like grass
and Frozen grass coffees and coffees and
coffees and coffees a McDonald's has a
assortment of featured drinks espresso
drinks mochas iced lattes let's get all
that on the screen see all these things
this is the cold brew this is so strong
I think each of you should eventually
take a sip but you'll not believe how
strong the cold brew is oh my God French
vanilla
that's the exact opposite this is like
so sweet mocha who doesn't want hot
chocolate first thing in the morning
hilarious people are buying that oh this
the premium roast coffee I know I'm kind
of distant on it but they're actual
coffee the actual McDonald's coffee I
think it's very good they're they're a
good contender in the coffee game I
think in the faster than coffee game
especially the horrible PR nightmare
they had when they like destroyed that
lady's crotch with their super hot
coffee it is a comeback story McDonald's
almost killing along with second degree
burns from boiling hot coffee to these
nice little fun Cafe drinks that would
happen
pour this all over my crotch you can get
the iced coffee drinks they're like this
this is the mocha McDonald's in China
also has a late night menu they only
have one item but this is worth it I got
it last night these are marinated
chicken bones they don't sound very
appealing but the Chinese name is word
play on an idiom which kind of means the
highest level of artistry and when I
opened up this box
[Music]
I literally heard Angels going oh this
is actually a street food from some
place up in Northeast China called
xinyang Chinese people love fiddly stuff
and meat on the bone it's just that much
more tasty
ah still incredible even cold you know
the Box actually says marinated chicken
bones be careful what may contain bones
and you're actually supposed to spit the
bones out but I'm
having so much fun eating this thing I
actually eat the bones too it's spicy
it's sour it's sweet ah and it just
absolutely Divine I can see how people
would be inspired after eating this
so McDonald's came to China in 1990 and
then it opened in Beijing in 92 and back
then that was the largest McDonald's in
the world they had 700 seats on opening
day they served 40 000 people and people
didn't go there for the food it was a
place to be seen like McDonald's was a
window to the West it was a Cosmopolitan
place to experience capitalism in a way
but over time it became a trendy hangout
spot for City kids after school they go
there to do their homework it still very
much is middle class I remember actually
when I came to visit China 20 years ago
my aunts greeted me at the airport with
bags of McDonald's and I was actually
kind of offended that they would bring
junk food to meet me as opposed to real
Chinese food but for them McDonald's was
the best of the best it was all the
prestige hey to me McDonald's if it
comes a fast food it is number one in
the US dare I say the world if you just
want a good hot meal where you know
exactly what's going to taste like and
get it and go McDonald's never fails
waiting in line getting it to drive
through to get it lickety-split now that
really they leaned really big into
delivery since covid Amanda McDonald's
is showing up right away and I love it
it's dangerous uh I can't remember the
last time I've eaten inside a McDonald's
so I usually dine in at McDonald's but I
find that in China they focus more on
delivery and they promise to get
everything delivered within 30 minutes
which they actually keep to and that's
incredibly impressive last night I
ordered the chicken carcass it took 28
minutes got a Big Mac earlier that was
10 minutes so they are very very
punctual they're also open for very long
from Seven till 10 pm and there are many
24-hour branches so extremely convenient
now McDonald's channels as an American
brand so they have American Classics on
the menu hamburgers chicken sandwiches
but they they kind of assimilated and
made popular the burger culture in this
country it's hard to say because I feel
like the American taste is McDonald's I
think McDonald's has actually adapted
pretty well to Chinese tastes besides
the spicy burger and wings and the
grilled chicken sandwich which have all
become best sellers McDonald's actually
uses chicken thigh meat instead of
breast meat in all of its chicken
burgers except for the McChicken and I
think that's because Chinese people
think chicken breast is dry and they've
also got lots of time limited specials
when it comes to desserts like the
mantle Burger which is kind of like a
Chinese bun and even cilantro sundae
McDonald's everyone's going to
McDonald's Burger King's been going out
to McDonald's since what the 60s every
Burger chain try to
get some sort of edge of McDonald's
we're fancier we're got different
varieties of stuff McDonald's is number
one here now and forever the McDonald's
logo should be in the American flag damn
it so China is McDonald's second largest
market Buy store account after the US in
China there are over 5 000 McDonald's
locations but KFC has over 9 000 they
actually came here first so it's KFC
then McDonald's then a local brand
called bikos which does both Fried
Chicken and Burgers so they're really
just fighting an uphill battle
in China a Big Mac costs 25 Yen a Big
Mac in the US costs 5.29 make it a Big
Mac meal with a medium fries and medium
Coke and it's 36 Yen if you want to go
large that's 4 Yen extra for a grand
total of 40 Yen if you're making a meal
with the medium fries and medium drink
price goes up to 9.29 upgrade that to a
large and it's 10.79 our Big Mac large
meal costs 86 more so our Big Mac meal
is cheaper but at the same time the
average daily wage of a cabbie in
Beijing is about 200 yen give or take
and so this would be 20 of their salary
so it's still not really something that
you would eat on a regular basis but
maybe splurgeon
let's talk nutrition this is that very
big mac again in the U.S it's 590
calories and all this stuff in China Our
Big Mac has 524 calories 26 grams of fat
45 grams of carbs 27 grams of protein
and 877 milligrams of sodium what if we
did a Cabo starting with the medium
fries this adds 320 calories to the meal
and all this stuff while a medium fries
in China contains 290 calories 13 grams
of total fat
35.9 grams of carbs we're not sure if it
contains any sugars
4 grams of protein and 252 milligrams of
sodium but you need some to drink and
the medium Coke to that and this kicks
your meal up another 210 calories we'll
do the same here's everything in a
medium Coke in China
148 calories that leaves the grand total
for the China meal at
962 calories while in the us the total
ends up looking like this 1 120 calories
and all this other stuff get a load of
that sodium though no take the box out
you can't throw away the Box some kind
of hoop just trying to build some more
Yao Ming's here give me a couple decades
now usually when a foreign brand comes
to China they get a Chinese name too and
sometimes it's a transliteration
sometimes they get really nice meanings
as well for McDonald's the Chinese name
is my dangla which is a transliteration
but you could also kind of take it to
mean that wheat is obligated to work for
you